The 2011 Jeep Grand Cherokee uses a
smart key system with RFID technology.
Programming a new key fob involves
teaching the vehicle's body control
module to recognize it. The key fob
contains a transponder chip and buttons
for lock, unlock, panic, and trunk
release. The BCM can pair with up to
eight keys. There are a few ways to do
this. Keep in mind that enhanced
security protocols post 2020 may make
DIY attempts harder, and encrypted keys
often require dealer tools. As of 2025,
all 2011 models are eligible for free
security updates at the dealer, which
includes the key fob programming. For
non-encrypted keys, a standard DIY
method exists. Insert a working key into
the ignition, then cycle the ignition.
Turn the key to on, then run, then off.
Press the new key fob buttons in
sequence to program it. Ensure your
vehicle battery is above 12 volts and
there are no active security faults.
Success rates are higher for basic fobs
than aftermarket ones. Encrypted keys,
common in 2011 models, typically require
a dealer tool due to BCM security codes.
Attempting to force programming can
trigger a lockout. Remember, post2020
security updates may impact DIY success.
If unsuccessful, a dealer visit is
recommended. Also be aware that users
report occasional glitches with cold
weather affecting signal strength and
increased complaints about battery life,
typically 2 to 3